euh merci en tout cas d'avoir été là
merci allez on va revenir euh sur ce
drame en terme en colère réaction des
suspects un proche de Thomas la victime
du drame de crpol est avec nous ce soir
euh plusieurs individus ont été mis en
cause et interpellés quelques jours
après avoir pris la fuite après avoir
poignardé Thomas ce samedi soir dans la
Drome lors d'une fête organisée dans un
petit village une marche blanche a été
organisée ainsi que les obsèques de
Thomas aujourd'hui mais où en est
l'enquête qui est Karim ce jeune homme
sur les réseaux qui se dit être proche
des agresseurs on va revenir sur les
derniers éléments de cette affaire avec
avec Jacky un ami des parents de Toba
qui va venir finalement avec sa femme
également c'est ce qu'on vient de me
dire regardez petit Réap il seront avec
nous je sera près pour un gros
témoignage et vous nous donnerez les
dernières infos g c'est
[Musique]
parti samedi dernier c'est un véritable
drame qui s'est déroulé dans la Drome où
le jeune Thomas 16 ans a été tué à
l'arme blanche lors d'un bal de village
mon meilleur ami qui était en train Deir
un massage
cardiaque c'est les pires Sensations du
Monde et alors qu'un individu qui des
fait est aujourd'hui suspecté d'être
l'auteur du coup mortel plusieurs
personnes ont été interpellées et
placées en garde à vue l'intervention du
GGN il une dizaine de véhicules
bouleversé par la mort du jeune homme
Des milliers de personnes ont participé
à une récente marche blanche et à ses
obscs ce matin pour lui rendre un
dernier hommage c'est pas normal ces
choses qui se sont passées il faut qu'on
qu'on le dise tout enterement colère
réaction des suspect un proche de Thomas
la victime du drame de crpol témoigne ce
soir dans
TPMP merci Jackie et Catherine d'être
avec nous ce soir merci beaucoup d'être
là vraiment merci parce que je sais que
vous avez une journée très très
harraçante puisque vous étiez à
l'enterrement bien entendu tout à
l'heure vous êtes venu exprès et ce soir
vous êtes venus non seulement pour nous
parler bien sûr de cette affaire mais
aussi pour faire passer un message parce
que c'est vrai que dans ce village tout
le monde a été traumatisé par ce qui
s'est passé et par la mort de de Thomas
et c'est vrai que même nous qui ne le
connaissons pas ici le profil de Thomas
c'est un garçon voilà on se dit tous
c'est un garçon voilà qui qui coche
toutes les cases de quelqu'un qu'on
adore voilà un sportif un mec qui fait
pas d'histoire qui est voilà qui est qui
qui qui a un amour de gar que tout le
monde dit et vraiment je vous dis on se
dit tous c'est c'est incroyable et c'est
ça nous met dans une colère monstre et
c'est vrai qu'on se dit à chaque fois je
vais vous dire à chaque fois qu'il y a
des drames c'est ce qu'on dit ici à
chaque fois on se dit on espère que ça
va pas il va pas en avoir d'autres
et on fait l'émission tous les jours et
je peux vous dire tous les deux jours
tous les TR jours il y a des drames qui
arrivent et et je sais que je suis sûr
que jacie et Catherine ils sont venu
nous voir ce soir aussi pour se dire
voilà on espère que ça se reproduira pas
parce que forcément vous êtes très
choqué de ce qui s'est passé Jacy est-ce
que et Catherine est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce que vous ressentez
aujourd'hui
vous on ressent beaucoup beaucoup de
haine c'est c'est horrible une affaire
comme ça je c'est inadmissible ça
devrait pas exister ça devrait pas
arriver on a bien senti que ces jeunes
étaient venus là pour pour pour tuer en
fait des couteaux c'est clair clair donc
c'est vrai
que on ressent la haine vraiment de la
haine laine Catherine je vous sens aussi
ému et énervé ce que j'ai vu quand vous
ê arrivé oui à tout vous dire en fait
jusqu'à 15h on savait pas qu'on venait
ouais c'est vrai jusqu'à 15h quand même
et et finalement on est allé ce matin
aux obsèques on est allé à la marche
blanche
on a trouvé que les gens étaient très
dignes à aucun moment il y a eu des
débordements ça je pense qu'il faut le
préciser parce que comme vous avez dit
tout au départ il y a plein de fit
divivers et les faits divers ben des
fois les gens se vengent sur n'importe
quoi font des débordements là il y en a
pas eu et surtout ce que je tiens à
préciser c'est que que ça soit la marche
blanche ou l'enterrement de ce matin
c'estil y avait une dignité parfaite
c'est-à-dire pas un bruit on était
presque 1000 ce matin et on entendait
les mouches voler franchement c'est et
ça c'est c'est un peu dur alors on est
allé
aussi au cimetière parce que bah on a
suivi la famille et puis au moment de se
rassemblé on était dans une salle des
fêtes on a communiqué avec les parents
et on a dit on a pris une décision et
finalement on veut on veut aller sur
place on nous a dit oui on vous a appelé
et et on nous a envoyé les billets le
temps de prendre un sac et et nous voilà
maintenant et on vient d'arriver là il y
a minutes je sais 5 minutes pourquoi
vous avez pris la décision de de venir
qu'est-ce que vous c'est moi c'est les
jeunes he tous les jeunes quand je les
ai vu souffrir comme ça ouais avoir le
courage aussi de porter le cercueil et
puis il y a quand même des jeunes qui
étaient là-bas enfin ils étaient au bal
ils ont échappé d'autres qui devaient
partir d'autres qui sont restés il y a
eu plein d'événements comme ça qui qui
fait que ben finalement ils étaient là
et ils ont participé à la bagarre aussi
quand même c'était quoi Thomas est-ce
que vous pour nous parler de Thomas euh
Catherine et Jacky Jacky v-y Jacky
Thomas Thomas on l'a vu grandir oui on
l'a vu
grandir c'est un gamin très très très
gentil très très
très
trèsable à la fête il aimait sourire
faire voilà un sportif c'est un sportif
déjà donc voilà il aimait il aimait les
copains toujours être avec les copains
faire la fête très joyeux et puis c'est
un petit qui était bah il était
capitaine de son équipe aussi de RB
c'est pas pour rien être capitaine de
équipe de de sport c'est c'est c'est pas
rien c'est c'est pour une raison bien
précise c'est que il était toujours là
pour calmer les esprits pour tout de
tout le monde et qu' y avait une petite
friction entre joueurs il allait voir
ses copains dire arrêtez faut pas faire
ça se fait pas
malheureusement c'est tombé sur lui il
méritait pas voilà c'est surtout pas
j'aimerais savoir votre première
réaction Catherine et Jacky quand vous
avez appris le drame bah c'est dans d'
droses circonstances pour nous aussi
notre fille est hospitalisée et quand on
est arrivé pour la voir elle dit je sais
pas comment vous dire ça mais j'ai je
viens de recevoir une photo et je pense
qu'il s'agit de Thomas et quand elle
nous a montré la photo voilà c'était on
l'a pris vraiment donc depuis dimanche
ben c'est c'est très compliqué quand on
vous raconte l'histoire ce qui s'est
passé et ces jeunes qui sont venus dans
le seul but de de de bah de de de avec
des couteaux et essayer de de de de
plter des garts on va pas on va pas on
va pas tourner autour du pot he tu
tu c'est c'est c'est quoi la réaction
parce que nous ici par exemple je vous
dis on s'est dit mais on a on est on a
eu un sentiment vraiment de de de de de
s dit mais de haine et de de colère
incroyable parce qu'on se dit c'est
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui il se
passe des choses qu'on c'est c'est c'est
devenu n'importe quoi des jeunes de 16
ans de qui viennent avec des couteaux
qui alors que c'était une fête où tout
se passait bien ou c'est c'est ça a été
quoi votre votre
réaction bah sur le moment euh c'est
vrai qu'on a du mal à y croire puis
après petit à petit et ben on apprend
des choses que finalement son frère y
était et qu'il a voulu porter secours
ben il en a pris plein le pauvre et vous
rendez compte de la culpabilité pour le
gamin là c'est pour son grand frère on y
a pensé on en a parlé si vous rendez
c'est pas son grand frère c'est le
deuxième c'est
entre frère et c'est le lui qui est au
milieu la première chose qu'il a dit à
ses parents j'ai pas pu le sauver non
mais vous rendez compte vous appelez
Jacy et Catherine je sais
que il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
n'osent pas témoigner parce qu'il il
serait encore
menacé bah en tout cas ils doivent avoir
peur ça on le sait pas c'est incroyable
oui la peur non mais la peur existe bien
sûr la peur existe
ement c'est c'est c'est affreux c'est
affreux vivre comme ça je ve dire avec
une peur quand tu es jeune je dire aussi
maintenant on se demande si pour faire
le pourtant nous on est pe on est
dansaladrome l'adrome c'est c'est c'est
quand même rural c'est assz rural petit
village on voit ça les jeunes ont
l'habitude de faire la fête le soir ils
se rassemblent tous très Conval très
très sympa et là d'un coup là il AR
chose comm ça je sais que vous détestez
que les médias parlent de Rix et de
bagarre ce qu'on a entendu
des gens toujours les
mêmes les amis Gill notamment qui parl
de r non mais je rigole là g jqu un peu
mais c'est vrai que on a vu des gens
d'extrême gauche qui parlent de Rix qui
veulent pas absolument parler de
d'expédition punitive moi c'est comme ça
que je je je je définiraiai ce qui s'est
passé excusez-moi pour moi il y a pas de
r une Rix une Rix voilà c'est ça on est
d'accord hein donc il a pas de de bandes
qui s'affront c'est pas de bandes qui
s'affrontent désolé c'est des jeunes qui
viennent juste pour CIR et faire une
expédition punitive et et peut-être tuer
des personnes qui étaient dans une fête
je sais qu'est-ce qui vous énerve comme
moi vous êtes énervé quand les gens
disent Rix c'est c'est quoi c'est
n'importe quoi enement c'est n'importe
quoi oui oui oui complètement ce n'est
pas du tout une Rix les jeunes qui
étaient dans le bal ils avaient aucune
aucune envie de faire mavaise intion
mauvaise intention voilà il é là ils
étaient là pour s'amuser pour faire la
fête je veux dire les autres sont bien
arrivés dans un motif bien précis avec
des couteaux dans les poches quand même
donc le mot Rix vous qui êtes proche de
la famille qui connaissez Thomas moi je
vous dis quand j'entends ça je me dis
mais vraiment on marche sur la tête dans
ce pays il y a certaines personnes qui
qui se rendent pas compte de de ce
qu'elles peuvent dire dans les médias
euh qu'est-ce que vous dites Catherine
ce que je je sens vraiment que ça ça ça
vous ça vous énerve comme nous que ça
vous touche oui oui oui
après quel que soit de la manière dont
on parle où on place les mots
l'essentiel c'est que il y a eu ce drame
et et et bon après peut-être qu'il y a
des gens qui qui qui vont reprendre tout
ça mais non ce qu'il faut se dire c'est
que c'est un drame et quelle que soit la
manière dont dont s'est présenté le
drame il est là en fait j'ai un message
incroyable qui vient d'arriver euh qui
me dit so monsieur an je voulais juste
dire à la famille que je leur souhaite
beaucoup de courage la vie n'est pas
juste c'est la maman de l'Ola qui
m'envoie rappeler du drame de Lola qui
m'envoie ce message et vous rendez
compte quand elle et ça vous rendez
compte quand elle voit ouais elle nous
regarde certainement elle nous regarde
la maman de Lola et d'ailleurs je pense
très fort à elle bien entendu et tous
les jours elle le sait euh et voilà
j'essaie de voilà et et on est on espère
pouvoir la voilà l'aider un jour parce
qu'elle est dans un état lamentable et
la maman de Lola quand elle vous voit ce
soir elle doit se dire on m'avait dit on
a entendu hein on va tout faire pour que
ça se reproduise pas pour qu'il y ait
plus de c'est pas le même drame mais
elle comprend la la la détresse bien sûr
de des proches des parents des parents
et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui c'est
c'est je vous dis en faisant cette
émission toutes les semaines on se dit
faut pas que ça recommence et on voit
des des des des personnes qui viennent
parler qui disent bah on va tout faire
pour que ça se reproduise plus qu'il ait
plus de drame on a eu le professeur on a
eu l'Ola on a eu Thomas on a eu c'est
c'est c'est ça a des disparitions tous
les jours incroyable on a plein
d'affaires qui sont encore en cours et
qui sont pas RA
et c'est vrai que vous êtes pas dit dans
quel monde on vit vous qui êtes dans un
village tranquille si et vous rendez
contre les organisateurs mais oui la
culpabilité en déc et qui va organiser
quelque chose maintenant dans la Drome
je sais pas rendez compte le traumatisme
vous rendez compte la la prochaine fête
chez vous quand il y a une fête c'est un
événement c'est voilà c'est c'est c'est
je sais que voilà comme vous avez dit
Thomas il aimre avec ses potes il aim
aujourd'hui qui va mais mon mari il
organise régulièrement des
manifestations il est président d'un
club aujourd'hui vous allez rien faire
non on peut pas on peut plus on peut
plus on peut plus rien faire on a peur
on a la peur on c'est trébec toute
manifestation on prend des risques on
prend beaucoup de risques et en tant
queorganisateur après ça serait
compliqué parce qu'après ça voilà souci
malheureux mais c'est malheureux je vous
jure c'est c'est parce que il y a ce
drame mais il y a l'après aussi et c'est
vrai que ils se rendent pas compte ces
jeunes du mal qui